as we just saw Bree lead it's the
beginning for her but the end for others
so this was an emotional what was it
what was the ending like how emotional
wasn't good it was emotional III was you
know and again this has nothing to do
with what happens in the plot regardless
of what happens in the plot I would
still feel a real sense of emotional as
well because it is the culmination of
you know 10 years and what 21 22 movies
are something like that it's it's a huge
chunk of my life and and the experiences
I've had the friendships I've made mean
a lot to me and to here you know you're
wrapped on the last movie just it did it
shook me up yeah you got the shield did
you get the suit no I've been asking for
the suit I'll get to argue I'll get you
can't get the sound get this suit they
gave me the shield to give me the cowl
and on this one I'm saying come on guys
finish the set give me the whole shebang
Hemi got dolls he did yeah would you get
your whole suit away my stretchy pants
yeah what would you do with the suit if
you got it ah you know I'm sure my
buddies would you know it'd be more fun
for my friends and for me but I don't
know I probably just you know the real
question is which suit what I want what
song would you want Civil War well
that's the real question I don't know
maybe maybe maybe maybe Winter Soldier
did was it tough for you on the last day
or were you just like okay look let's
all go around let's kiss and hug no it
was tough it was I mean it's been a huge
part of my life and
I love these guys and I also you know
you never know what Wow they learn
didn't you think you know and then you
just find out you didn't know is every
day then full of surprises on the set
like you're on the second you're like
wait a minute I thought I got dummy
scenes what they had scripts that had
dummy scenes in them so I'd come one day
to shoot like him and someone get
married and then I'd find out it was him
in someone else that got married you
thought you would learn we thought you
would learn uh what is it like for
somebody new like Brehon how do you
integrate her into the groove it's so
seamless I mean with every with every
moving there's more people that join the
family and I don't know whether it's
Kevin Feige Z bility to pick people that
will kind of slide right in or not but
but there's never been someone that's
been like oh this is uh it always just
feels so effortless there are these
great actors you know that's the one
thing marble well except for us is there
anybody in particular you'll miss no no
of course well I mean obviously
everybody but but I really we never we
never really fall out of contact
though at least the main the the og sex
I mean like the og six the the that
group we have a text chain and you know
from the time we're at the time we start
press we're always oh what is the og six
Oh like no what is always texting like
crazy
it's inappropriate
yeah it's fun it's a bunch of people sat
together on set for life
for Scarlett Scarlett yeah I mean
assistance of people but it's mostly
like just out of the blue you're gonna
text up some like I miss you guys so
much and then everyone knows everyone
goes out to do other jobs and you know
when you start other jobs every movie is
gonna have a different vibe in a dynamic
and sometimes those vibes are great and
wonderful and sometimes they're not what
you you know what you had and and it's
it's easy to kind of be like you know
I'm really missing my my old crew did
Robert get the day off
how does he get that does he have like a
special feeling we're 30 day off today
see you not here no he's not here it is
oh really yeah he did a Disney thing
yesterday though yeah he did we didn't
do that yeah we were flying that we had
no choice we were kind of like bouncing
around Rambo and everybody yes he's our
he's doing something today all right
we're doing a piece on the 15th
anniversary of 13 going on 30
what do you remember about working with
Jen garner from that movie
sweet this time you know we were both
what he was she was a big star and but I
was kind of just starting out and and
and she was just so lovely and we were
making this really sweet movie that had
a great message for young girls and and
in Gary Winnick who's you know since
passed away it was we were all sort of
like coming into our own at that moment
and we really love that story
and Jen was just transformed into a 13
year old girl is really amazing by the
way when she fit into Marvel Universe
I'm surprised she's not really here yet
actually at this point I'm surprised any
actor I see anybody you want love Jen
garner by the way anybody you want
anybody you think that they should add
anybody specific just before you got so
you take it
Benicio del Toro he's Nicolas Cage
you're kind of like a great bad guy they
might be a little kick ass overlap
though he's so good now you're right
[Music]